THIS COUNTRY EVER BEEN
SUCCESSFUL?
JOHN AVLON WITH THE REALITY
CHECK.
>>> IN OUR POLARIZED HYPER
PARTISAN TIMES THE EXTREMES SEEM
TO DISPROPORTIONATELY DOMINATE
OUR DEBATES.
THIS ISN'T YOUR IMAGINATION.
LESS THAN 10% OF HOUSE SEATS ARE
COMPETITIVE DUE TO THE
REDISTRICTING.
MOST OF OUR STATE LEGISLATIVERS
OVERWHELMINGLY A RED OR BLUE
HUE.
DESPITE THE FACT MOST AMERICANS
SAY THEY ARE MODERATE RATHER
THAN LIBERAL OR CONSERVATIVE.
MOST MODIFY MORE AS INDEPENDENT
NOT REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT.
WHICH SUGGESTS THERE IS A MARKET
FAILURE IN OUR POLITICS.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE, A FEW
BRAVE SOULS DECLARE THEIR
INDEPENDENCE FROM THE TWO-PARTY
SYSTEM.
WE SAW IT THIS WEEK WITH ANDREW
YANG, WHO IS FORMING A NEW PARTY
CALLED FORWARD.
AND EVAN McMULLEN CHALLENGED
MIKE LEE AS AN INDEPENDENT.
SMART STRATEGY FOR AN AEPT TRUMP
REPUBLICAN.
PARTISANS SEE THESE MOVES AS
NAIVE AND INSANE.
PROPONENTS SEE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR CONSTRUCTIVE DISRUPTION.
SO LET'S DIG INTO THE DATA AND
SEE WHO IS RIGHT.
RECORD 62% OF AMERICANS SAY
THERE IS A NEED FOR A THIRD
PARTY NOW, ACCORDING TO GAP ALL.
33% SAY THE TWO PARTIES ARE
DOING AN ADEQUATE JOB.
AND THE RISE OF INDEPENDENT
VOTERS THE PAST TWO DECADES.
AS OF LAST MONTH, 41% OF
AMERICANS IDENTIFY AS
INDEPENDENT COMPARED TO 29% FOR
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS ALIKE.
YOU'VE GOT TO GO BACK TO 2004 TO
FIND A SUSTAINED PERIOD WHERE
THERE WERE FEWER INDEPENDENTS
THAN REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS.
AND NOT COINCIDENTALLY, THE TWO
PARTIES HAVE ONLY GOTTEN MORE
POLARIZED SINCE THAT TIME.
SO WHY HASN'T A VIABLE THIRD
PARTY MATERIALIZED?
WELL, A BIG PART OF THE PROBLEM
IS STRUCTURAL.
WHILE THE CONSTITUTION DOES NOT
MENTION POLITICAL PARTIES,
GEORGE WASHINGTON WAS OUR ONLY
INDEPENDENT PRESIDENT TO DATE.
THE U.S. DOESN'T HAVE A
PARLIAMENTARY SYSTEM.
MOREOVER, STATE LAWS MAKE
GETTING ON THE BALLOT A HASSLE
IN FEDERAL RACES.
WE HAVE WHAT'S KNOWN AS
AYSMMETRIC POLARIZATION, MEANING
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS MORE FAR
RIGHT THAN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS FAR LEFT.
INDEPENDENTS COULD ACT AS
SPOILERS, PARTICULARLY TRUE IN
PRESIDENTIAL RACES WHERE THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE MEANS IT IS
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR A THIRD
PARTY CANDIDATE TO WIN.
LOOK AT THE 1912 PROGRESSIVE BID
WHICH TOPPED OUT AT 27% OF THE
POPULAR VOTE.
THE NEXT WAS IN 1992 WHEN ROSS
PEROT WON NEARLY 19% BUT NOT A
SINGLE ELECTORAL VOTE.
IN FACT, THE LAST SUCCESSFUL
THIRD PARTY WAS THE ABRAHAM
LINCOLN LED REPUBLICAN PARTY OF
1860.
BUT IT IS A MISTAKE TO LOOK ONLY
THROUGH THE PRISM OF
PRESIDENTIAL POLITICS.
BECAUSE THERE HAVE BEEN SIX
INDEPENDENT ELECTED GOVERNORS
SINCE 1990.
ONLY ONE ELECTED TO A SECOND
TERM.
THAT IS ANGUS KING OF MAINE.
HE CAUCUSES WITH THE HAVE THES
LIKE BERNIE SANDERS FROM
VERMONT.
BOTH YANG AND McMULLEN SAID IT
IS A WAY TO SOLVE OUR PROBLEMS,
AN OFF-RAMP TO COUNTER THE
ONE-PARTY RULE OF DEEP RED OR
BLUE STATES.
BIG PICTURE, IT REQUIRES IN
JUSTING THE INCENTIVE STRUCTURES
THAT PUSH CANDIDATES TO THE
EXTREME IN POLITICS.
THAT MEANS ELECTION REFORMS LIKE
OPEN PRIMARIES, RANK CHOICE
VOTING END OF THE RIG SYSTEMED
OF REDISTRICTING.
CHANGE THE RULES, CHANGE THE
GAME.
THE DRIVE BEHIND THE THIRD-PARTY
DREAM IS AT THE END OF THE DAY
PUTTING COUNTRY OVER PARTY.
IT'S A GOOD-FAITH EFFO